this morning cleanup and Recovery efforts resume
after tornadoes ripped across the south at least
nine people are dead including seven in hard hit
Alabama the Twisters left a trail of Destruction
in the historic civil rights community of Selma
just before the start of the Dr Martin Luther
King Jr holiday weekend the tornadoes ripped off
roofs crushed cars and uprooted trees and utility
poles this morning several thousand customers are
still without electricity Omar via Franca has more
from Selma we ran in this room right here Amanda
McLeod says it's a miracle she survived a tornado
that destroyed this Selma Church daycare she's
being called a hero for how she and her fellow
teachers protected eight infants as the tornado
tore through the building I had the seven week old
here and I think she's four or five months old
here and I was sitting down and when the power
went out I was just like you know I just shielded
him the little the little one the seven week old
one Selma Alabama took a direct hit a 20-mile path
of Destruction cut through its Historic downtown
buildings bulldozed and residents left stunned
it's bad down here like Louisiana it's bad oh my
gosh the storm was part of a system that battered
California this week with more to come at least
two people were killed in Georgia including a
five-year-old boy after a tree fell on his car
and near Montgomery Alabama cleanup after
a likely ef-3 tornado damaged or destroyed
roughly 40 homes Emergency Management director
Ernie Baggett says it could have been worse the
school system kept all the kids in place rather
than putting them on the buses and sending them
home early do you think that saved lives oh no
doubt 40 tornadoes were reported now thousands
of people are still without power but we have
seen Crews from nearby States working to fix that
but it will take weeks to clean this up for CBS
Saturday morning Omar villafranca Selma Alabama